if I can be to my games I can be a candy
challenge no he beats me at being loud I
went at games let's do this day some
people calls coworkers i calls best
friends i costco we met at a candy store
and i had to say what's up to this guy
because he was always eating tune out of
a can so there were just more questions
than answers I always have candy in my
purse
I'm only competitive at things I'm good
at so if it's candy related I will throw
it out extend tape measure to 4 feet and
hold the end just above the edge of the
cup if tape measure ever comes into
contact with cup player will be
penalized by spinning around 3 times
lever has the most candy in the cup at
the end of 60 seconds wins oh my god
tape measure I need you to hold strong
my mic ricocheted off the ring view on
Julian surfing I did hit the glass one
oh my Maltesers are just too buoyant my
Maltesers are joyful Maltesers that like
to jump oh I think we could call it
there right that's a hard 60 now it
feels so good about this suck the candy
out of a bowl and place them into the
cup oh no oh my god this is so much
harder than I thought Tracy actually
real quick there we go okay perfect
we don't have to count it but I do you
just eyeball it and just see you were
more cunning in your cheating that's the
only reason why I'm not either - yes -
using the springboard shoot as many
candies through the hoop as possible
whoever can hit the most baskets in 60
seconds wins also I am living for that
sounds fine all right white can we eat
them now they're really good
listen everyone every game listen you
must you be terrify me oh how cute is
that and I get my Maltesers don't get
enough
where's your trophy it's they must have
forgot it can we get another do we have
the second place one trophy
[Music]